Trù bốt trải hết tốt lực trời la vào gần dắng, nhá xuất sân và tỏa lối.
Đây là một trong hàng loạt xử cố sẽ ra khi các lội trù bốt tập luyện trực thế và hội trù bốt hình người thế giới hàng ngàn không trăm 2 mì sau tại bất cình trù bước.
Mẫu trù bốt xup mà man của unitary, gây chủ ý khi đặt tốt đổ hơn 1.5 phía lo met trên liền trong một lần trải hữu.
Cũng máy không kịp giám tốt la có đường trải và đâm vào các tủ định bên cạnh.
Ờ một kinh nguyên khác, mẫu hắt mẫu đàn trái nước trúc bất hợt tông mạnh vào gời cháng, sau khu vầy chàng, trù bốt mật ngược, rãn trọng vài bước trôi nhà xuống, với lửa ở phần thân.
Yên yên truyên sau đó cho biết trù bốt bị giải ở phần L, trong các bối tập bông đá, trù bốt của bước sto trò bò tích cũng liên tục và chạm mất thằng bằng vàng nhà xuống sân.
Chúc khi tự lý nhảy đại tiếp tục khi đâu.
Nếu sự có này sẽ ra trong quá trình các lộ trọ bốt thử nghiệm và tinh trịnh khả năng vận động, những thằng bằng của trọ bốt, chúc khi mức vào thì đấu chính thức.
Thế vận hội trọ bốt hình người thế giới lần thứ 2, những ra từ ngày 2020, 2020, quy tổ hình 2020, của sấu trăm sáo mình sáo đổi đến từ bự sáo bốt dạ.
Các trọ bốt trần tài ở nhiều người dùng từ điên cình bống đá đến các bạn hay mô khỏng công việc thực tế.